안녕하세요 시드 웨어입니다 언제가나
했던 2024년도 이제 마지막
페이지가 보입니다 개인적으로 꽤나
파란만장한 년에 보내서 시간이 어떻게
흘러갔는지 모르겠습니다 올해로 저는
지금 있는 패션 회사에 입사한지 만
2년이 됐어요이 회사에 덜컥 합격하고
제게 딱 3주 정도의 시간이
주어졌었다 본 적이 없었기 때문에
저는 해외로 가기로 마음 먹었어요
여러 선택지 중 저는 베를린에
다녀왔습니다 베를린에서 11박
10일 유럽 여행을 가면 주로 사흘에
나을 주기로 이곳저곳 이동하면서
다니잖아요 아무래도 회사에 들어가면
긴 여유가 그리울 것 같아서 한
곳에만 오래 눌러 앉아 보기로
결정했습니다 그리고 정말 후회 없는
시간이었어요 제가 베를린을 결정한
데는 여러 이유가 있었습니다 일단
맥주도 저렴하고 블로 보의 매장도
많고 당시에 비엔날레도 열리고
있었고요 그런데 가장 결정적으로 저를
베를린으로 끌어당긴 한 브랜드가
있습니다 바로 오늘 소개할 브랜드인
블레스 블레스를 아시는 분들 중엔
나이키 트레이닝 팬츠랑 리바이스
데님을 합친 오버 조 행진으로 처음
알게 된 분들이 계실 거예요 사실
제가 그랬거든요 블레스는 생각보다 긴
역사를 갖고 있는 브랜드입니다
오스트리아 출신의 대지의 하이스 독일
출신의 디자이너 이네스 카이
1995년에 결성한 브랜드인데요 가장
먼저 주목을 받은 건 레스에서 영국의
싱어송라이터로드 스튜어트의
헤어스타일에서 차관에 만든 포로된
가발입니다 아이디 매거진의 실린
광고를 통해 연락을 받게 되고이
가발은 매종 마르 라에서 1997년
FW 쇼에
등장합니다 이후에 수많은 협과 를
진행하면서 블레스는 패션계에서
본인들의 독보적인 위치를 공고의
했어요 지금 보여 드리고 있는 건
블스에서 브랜드의 25주년의 기념에
출시한 서적입니다 여기 보면 꽤
재미난 이야기들이 많이 있어요 몇
가지만
말씀드릴게요 첫 번째는 2010년
프랑크푸르트에 위치한 mmk
미술관에서 했던 참여형 전시입니다
당시에 나러 패션이라는 제목의 전시가
열리면서 참여하는 브랜드들에게 패션쇼
위한 예산을 지급했어요
블레스는이 돈으로 패션쇼를 여지 않고
되래 본인들의과 시즌 제품들을
구매하는데 썼습니다 이렇게 모은
블레스의 예전 옷들을 미술관에서
전시했어요 전시에 방문한 관람객들은
이옷을 공짜로 가져갈 수가 있었습니다
대신에 블레스의 판정단에게 내가 왜이
옷을 가져야 하는지 설명을 통해
납득시켜야 했어요 그래서 보면 관
객은 장황하게 논거를 펼치기도 하고
어떤 어린아이는 모자가 따뜻해서 갖고
싶어요라는 식으로 단순하게
이야기하기도 합니다 그리고 넘겨보면
베를린에 위치한 kw 인스티튜 오
아트에서 진행한 25주년 기념 전시에
대한
내용입니다 제가 베를린에 갔을 때
사실이 전시를 봤어요 한국에서
비행기랑 숙박 빼고 제가 유일하게
예약했던게이 전시입니다
이 전시가 독특한 건 일주일 중
금요일 딱 하루 오후 2시 시까지
3시간만 열었다는 점입니다 전시에
가서 이유를 알 수 있었어요 전시를
제외한 시간은 실제로 예술가들이
거주하는
공간이었습니다 그러니까 풀어 얘기하면
전시 관람이라 단 에어 BNB 같은
곳에 제가 방문을 한 겁니다 전신대
책자도 없고 관람객도 저 분이었고
심지어 안에서 예술가 분이 체크아웃
전에 청소기를 돌리느라 저랑 큐레이터
분은 문앞에서 3분 정도 기다렸다가
둘러볼 수
있었습니다이 공간은 정말 사람이 살
수 있는 공간처럼 돼 있어요 안방도
있고 침대도 있고 부엌도 있고
화장실까지 있습니다 그런데 안에 있는
모든게 다 블레 침대 커튼 의자
청소기 커버 심지어 벽지까지
인상깊었던 부분 중 하나는 부엌 거실
한쪽에 축구장 벽지가 있었어요 이건
블레스이 전시의 맞춤형으로 제작했다고
합니다 실제로 축구장 벽지 바깥으로는
벽지와 동일한 축구장이 있다고 해요
즉 건물 외관과 내부의 연결성을 위해
축구장 사진을 그대로 들여온 정말
블레스 다운 발상에 느껴지는
작품이었어요 또 안방에 있는 침대도
신
블레스를 좋아하는 분들이라면 보셨을
사람 두 명이 그려져 있는 이불이
있습니다 근데이 이불만 독특한게
아니라이 침대 구조도 했어요 우리가
통상적으로 아는 침대는 바닥보다 위에
있잖아요 그런데이 침대는 바닥으로
꺼져 있습니다 침대보다는 관에 들어가
있는 느낌이 들었어요 전시에 대한
개인적인 총평은 일단 저는 굉장히
좋았습니다 앞서 말씀드린 것처럼
어떻게 생각을하지 하는 참신한
작품들부터
왜 이런 생각을 하지 하는 충격적인
제품까지 정말
많았습니다 하지만 혼자 여러 가지
경험을 해볼 수 있었고 국내에서 편집
시합에 단순히 걸려 있는 블레스의
옷들만 보다가 블레라 공간에 체험해
보니까 제가 하던 블레스는 정말 반쪽
자리였다는 걸 깨달을 수 있었어요
개인적으로 2 30분 본이 블레스의
전시가 시간 넘게 본 베를린
비엔날레의 수십개 작품보다 더 인상
깊었습니다 이제 제가 갖고 있는
블래스 제품들을 조금씩 보여
드리겠습니다 처음 소개할 건 제가
구매한 첫 번째 블레스의 옷인
22aw 진스 프런트 블랙 코듀로이
데님 제품입니다 블래스 시그니처 럼
제작하는 앞뒤 판이 다른 소재로 되어
있는 바인데요 블레스의 나이키 오버
족 행진과 다르게이 제품은 앞판이
검정된 임 뒤판이 검정 코듀로이 되어
있습니다 제가이 바지를 구매하게 된
계기가 있는데요 블레스 전시를
기다리면서 앞에서 있는데 옆에 한
독개 남자분이 블래스 바지를 입고서
계셨어요 흰색 포플린 셔츠에 검정
페니 로퍼를 신고 바지로 이런 식의
앞뒤 소재가 다른 블래스 바지를 입고
있었습니다 그분을 보고 아 블레스
옷도 저렇게 포멀하게 혹은 일반 으로
입을 수 있다는 걸 깨달았습니다
그리고 비슷한 걸 마구 찾다가이
바지를
구매했고요이 제품으로 말미암아
블레스의 사이즈에 대해서 좀 말씀드려
볼게요 제가 구매한 건 스몰
사이즈인데 라지 사이즈와 미디 길이
말고는 거의 똑같았어요 블레스의
리메이크 제품들은 사이즈 체계가
무의미한 수준입니다 그래서 꼭
입어보고 구매하시는 걸 추천드려요
저는 베를린에서 보고 아른거려 가지고
결국 귀국 후에 에딕티드 해서
구매했습니다 저는이 제품을 입을 때
이런 식으로 무채색과 주로 같이
입습니다 그래야이 바지의 소재 차이에
집중이 되더라고요 너무 독특하지도
않고 적당한 포인트가 되어 마음에
드는 그런 바지입니다 다음으로 보여
드리는 건 블레스의 에코백입니다
뒤편은 아무것도 안 써 있고 앞판에는
블레스의 베린 매장이 표시된 지도가
프린팅 돼 있어요 이건 베린 블래스
매장에서 구매는
사실 정말 별거 없는 가방이 하지만
제게 큰 추억이 담겨 있습니다
블레스의 단독 매장은 전 세계 파리와
베를린 단 두 군데 있습니다 파리는
블래스 스토어 베를린은 블래스
홈이라고 부르는데요 여기서 베를린이
호인 이유는 그 독특한 위치에
있습니다 매장이 무슨 작은 아파트
단지 안에 있어요 들어가려면 먼저
밖에서 블래스라이저
그러면 먼저 철문이 열리고 거기서
아파트로 들어가 찾아야 합니다 처음에
막 헤매고 있다가 직원분이 테라스로
나와 손을 흔들어 주셔서 찾아갈 수
있었습니다 들어가면 그냥 우리가
흔히하는 아파트에는 집이에요 정말 그
사람 냄새 나는 집 대신 블래스
전시와 마찬가지로 어디를 둘러봐도
전부였습니다 매장에 방문하니까 손님이
저 크리스천이라는 이름의 직원분과
한시간 넘게 이야기를 나눴어요 옷
관련된 얘기도 하고 레스에 대한
얘기도 나눴습니다 에코백을 사면서
블레스의 핸들 스티커도 몇 장 받고
크리스찬이 또 편지를 써준 우편과
함께 에코백에이 시간에 추억하고자
사인도
받았습니다 크리스찬의 말에 빌리면
사람들이 블레스의 옷과 오부제 등을
보고 많은 영감을 받는다고
합니다 어서 보기 어려운 디자인이라
머리를 때리는듯한 그 충격을 받을
수밖에 없어요 베를린에 만약에
가신다면 블레스 매장은 강력하게
추천드립니다 그 어느 쪽으로든 선명한
기억이 될 겁니다 마지막으로 소개할
제품은 제가 가진 블래스 중에 가장
화려한 이사 SS 스케이터
쇼츠입니다이 제품을 구매하기 전에
제가 탱고로 소 꼬모에서 비슷하게
생긴 블레스의 같은 시즌 수영복
바지를 구매했어요 근데
너무 화려하고 길이도 너무 짧아
가지고 정말 수영할 때 말고는 기가
어렵더라고요 믿기 힘드실 수 있지만이
수영복을 제가 회사에 한 번 정도
입고 간 적이 있습니다 그때 정말
모두가 너무나도
질색했던 와중에 샵 아모멘토 흑백으로
된 같은 디자인의 제품을 보고 끌려서
결국 구매하게
됐습니다 보신 분들이 있을지
모르겠지만 얼마 전에 제가 이걸
미미미누님께
입혀드렸어요 출연 전에 미누 님
입혀드릴 킹 받는 걸 가져와 달라는
요청을 받아서 이걸 갖고
갔는데 모르겠어요 저도 잘 못 입는
바라서 영 끝나고도 제가 너무
죄송해서 사과 드렸는데이 자리를
빌려서 다시 한번
사과드립니다 죄송합니다 제가 앞서
올린 영상들을 보신 분들은 아시겠지만
전 좀 웬만해서 조용하게 입습니다
그런데 올해 여름에 옷 입는게 너무
재미가 없어 가지고 좀 화려한 바지가
끌리더라고요이 스케이터 쇼츠는 사람이
수백명 프린팅되어 있어 시끄럽긴
하지만 그래도 흑백이고면 바이라
생각보다는 덜 튀더라구요
그래도 여전히 정신 없는 바이긴
합니다 이분들이 누군지는 잘
모르겠어요 제 추측으로는 브랜드
25주년의 그간 이바지한 블레스의
사람들이 아닐까 싶습니다
이 바지를 입을 땐 나머지는 최대한
얌전하게 입으려고
해요 그래야 그나마 중화가 되더라고요
무채색의 니트 맨투맨 아니면 자켓
같은 걸 입습니다 기장이 좀 길고
통이 넓어서 어떻게 입어도 좀
스트리트한 무드가 느껴지는
바입니다 솔직하게 블레스의 모든
제품이 다 제취향은 아닙니다 자주
입기도 쉽지 않고요 그리고 블레스가
모두의 호감에서는 브랜드는 또 아닐
겁니다 다만 다른 브랜드로 대체가 안
되는 패션의 범주로 포괄하기 어려운
독특함이 있습니다 옷이나 일상이 좀
평이하다 느껴질 때 하나의 독특함이
필요할 때 블레스를 한 번쯤은
쳐다보고 경험해 볼 만하다고
생각합니다 오늘 제가 준비한 이야기는
여기까지입니다 감사합니다